- Le'Veon, time to wake up.
Time to go to
the Steelers facility today.
It's time to finally check in
and be a good teammate.
- Or we could never go back
and watch them
suffer into the ground!
- It's time to go in
and apologize to your teammates
tell them how much
you missed football.
- You heard
what they said about you
those offensive linemen.
How many touchdowns
have they scored?
James Conner,
you should shave his head
when you get to camp.
- Think big-picture, Le'Veon.
- So then what's
the bigger plan, angel?
- You can be a part of a winner.
This team can win
the Super Bowl, Le'Veon.
And you know what that means?
More dollars.
- We could buy so many jet skis,
Le'Veon
if you win the Super Bowl.
- Mutual funds with the extra
money, Le'Veon.
Mutual funds.